[Music]
Moscow's Macho Man some American muscle
and an unlikely political marriage some
refused to bless president is putting
himself over our country
knowing nods friendly handshakes and the
mother of all fallouts I did not think
this was a good moment for our country
the White House continues to fire back
he sees more and more every single day
that this is proving further and further
to be a total witch hunt but the
investigation into Russian meddling has
only intensified the indictment charges
12 Russian military officers for
conspiring to interfere with the 2016
presidential election and the man
holding the microscope has already filed
191 criminal charges the political fight
over the Russia investigation has
reached fever pitch there have been
indictments court appearances and a
constant eye on the president every mood
with Moscow but here are two things we
don't know were Washington even except
Robert mullahs findings and just how
much will the rest of America care
[Music]
[Music]
Donald Trump's trip to Helsinki to meet
Vladimir Putin muddied the political
waters for his own party and on Capitol
Hill unsettled senators grilled his
chief diplomats Foreign Relations
Committee will come to order
it's the president that causes people to
have concerns and I just I'd love to
have some insights into you as to for
instance at the Helsinki conference to
create an equivalence between our
intelligence agency and what Putin is
saying that shocks people is there a
strategy of this or is it what what is
it that causes the president to
purposely purposely create distrust in
these institutions and what we're doing
disagree with most of what you just said
there you somehow disconnect the
administration's activities from the
president's actions they're there
they're the one and the same make no
mistake who's fully in charge of this
the Mike Pompeo trying to say look at
our policies and the senators saying ah
look at what the president saying on
Twitter
that's not your policy and it really
raised this question of whether we have
to trump administration foreign policies
those of his Secretary of State and
other officials and those of the
President himself
watching their president appeared to
take poot inside was too much for some
and it prompted a rare correction I have
president putin he just said it's not
russia i will say this i don't see any
reason why it would be a sentence should
have been i don't see any reason why it
wouldn't be russia sort of a double
negative he does not seem to be
separating the question of russia
interfering in the election from the
question of his own legitimacy as a
leader and i think among his supporters
they feel the same way it's hard to say
let's get tough on russia for this
meddling because that means that we need
to be tough on the fact that they may
have interfered in a way that helped
Donald Trump they die in the seus make a
little bit of a mistake they analyze
every word they say did he say could it
have been did he say something positive
about Russia I think he loves Russia be
nice to get along with Russia but that's
okay
[Music]
Moscoe may be accused of targeting
America's democracy but at bury the
hatchet in King of Prussia Pennsylvania
some voters like the prospects of the
President carving out a new relationship
I would much rather have them close than
enemies that they know they're
portraying that they are so I would much
rather have them close together do you
like the idea of the president being
close to Vladimir Putin even if he may
have meddled in your election I mean it
doesn't bother me so you wouldn't mind
either way won't change your vote nope
not at all
does it worry you if the president's
pursuing a relationship with a man who
you might meddle in your election again
absolutely I mean it's a complete
conflict of interest so I would say you
know philosophically that's a problem to
go down that path it just doesn't feel
right we're turning our backs on our
allies we're turning our backs on our
country and we're not turning our backs
they found nothing I mean except for
maybe Russia put fake news up on
Facebook which isn't a surprise but as
far as I'm concerned they didn't find
anything with Russia however you see it
there is no smoking gun yet no concrete
sign of collusion after more than a year
of throwing everything at it the Milan
investigation has really done so far is
kind of scoped out the dimensions of
Russia's meddling but they have not so
far done a lot on what American citizens
did and whether any of those American
citizens were involved with the Trump
campaign Carter page a former foreign
policy adviser to the Trump campaign has
been on the FBI's radar newly released
documents show they believed he was
collaborating and conspiring with the
Russian government in 2016 he claims
their surveillance was unfairly based on
partisan opposition research in these
documents they accuse you of being an
agent of a foreign power
why are you absolutely not it's just
it's just so ridiculous that you know
where do you begin to start in terms of
setting the record straight I've never
been asked to do anything illegal
immoral unethical throughout the 25
years I've been looking at Russia and
spending time over there so it's
absolutely preposterous but did you ever
advise the Kremlin
you know I participated in a few
meetings back in 2013 when the g20 was
held in st. Petersburg myself and dozens
of business leaders and academics from
all around the world were doing that so
we had some meetings in Paris Geneva New
York etc you clearly feel positive about
Donald Trump's approach to Russia do you
think he could have done anything
differently
I think he has been just under such
tremendous constraints pressures and
abuses so in a lot of ways he he reminds
me of Nelson Mandela you know and a lot
of people were using the intelligence
apparatus to go after him in a in
illicit ways and I think there's there's
significant things that he's persevered
through Michael Cohen Trump's former
fixer isn't sounding quite as convinced
and the president's current lawyer is on
the attack the man is a liar a proven
liar there's no way you're gonna bring
down the president United States on the
testimony uncorroborated of a proven
liar he's reportedly prepared to tell
the FBI that then candidate Trump knew
about the infamous meeting at Trump
Tower where Russians were expected to
dish dirt on Hillary Clinton Paul
Manafort Trump's former campaign
chairman was there this week he's the
first to take the stand accused of fraud
which he denies
I think what we've learned from the
metaphor charges and many of the other
ways that Muller has been conducting the
investigation is that he has a wide
remit in terms of what he can
investigate and he is he is using that
you know he's going where the evidence
takes him and he is he is not afraid to
do that the Russia probe casts a long
shadow over key states like Pennsylvania
public faith in the man steering the
dizzying details has dipped and there's
skepticism in the air I don't think it's
a witch hunt I think the press in the
United States is paying more attention
to President Trump and and they're after
him all the time they won't let him
alone you know if he did something wrong
that's one thing but he ain't done
anything wrong yet do you trust the
Russia investigation I'll let you know
when it's over I mean I think I think I
do he's basically saying he trusted she
trusts Putin more than he does his own
FBI close to to region as far as I'm
concerned Trump and Putin relationship I
can't believe that American president
would be so enamored of a Russian leader
he seems to be leading us down a path
that we don't know where it's going
does it bother you the Russia meddled in
2016 I know don't care he won on that
hog one you got it
he's in there right guy for the job
gonna make it done the distant glow of
the midterms is looming and one glaring
central question remains unanswered did
Trump or his associates work with Russia
[Music]
the White House is currently eyeing up a
counter report and the president has
already written something more profound
into the American psyche just remember
what you're seeing and what you're
reading is not what's happening
alongside the statue of freedom that
stands over Congress is a new pillar of
politics doubt
[Music]
you
[Music]